how do you think the whole the book the
storybook of humanity kind of ends
do you think we get it look at it you're
looking at i think it ends in a
dystopian
place and what is dystopian it ends like
what does that mean dystopian utopians
like a perfect world dystopians like a
[ __ ] up
future like yeah i think it ends mad max
here's how i kind of internalize it
thanks nick um i think it's like
here's what i think it is i think
outside there's gonna be like
fights and and people be fighting each
other
hopefully they'll be fist fighting each
other inside of an olive garden olive
garden will become
it'll be a place for fighting
government's gonna be like snatching
people off
it's gonna be crazy right and then
you'll be inside your house
with like vr goggles on like doing
tick-tock dances
and outside there's going to be
explosions and you're just going to hear
gunshots and then
you just can't hear it because you're in
like this augmented reality world of
like
the whole thing is we just climbed into
the computer yeah when when this started
everybody was just like well the
outside's a problem
you're going to get sick somebody's
going to you know oh that's true now
we've all climbed into the computer
climbed in the computer we're just going
to live there forever
so humanity will it'll just get weirder
and weirder and weirder
to the point where if you're like hey
you want to go to the park somebody's
gonna be looking you go are you [ __ ]
sick
are you a [ __ ] sicko do you know
what's out there marauding gangs
coronaviruses diseases government agents
like
it's gonna get pedophilia
public school teachers the worst the
lowest of the low
and i think tick-tock is a great way to
take a glimpse into the future
because the news will be like
everybody's dying
and then the kids on tick tock are just
like yeah
you know just like this like
just just unbothered just completely
like
like they're teletubbies yeah just like
some kids getting molested in the
teletubbies they're just dancing on the
screen and they're just like
mouthing the words to songs they didn't
write yeah and they're just dancing
and and and that's kind of the beginning
of of and then you have this girl who
mouths trump like sarah cooper whatever
name is
who's whatever talented i'm not cheating
on her but like she just
like trump she like lip syncs trump so
he'll say something and she goes on tick
tock she's got this massive following
just like lip syncing
so it's going to be weird it's just like
it's going to be like
people lip syncing music or the words of
other people and people can be like
that's funny
it's gonna it's starting to feel strange
out there and i think it just gets
weirder and weirder
to the point where we all just want to
live in a video game
because it's more comforting than real
life and what about if semen comes out
of our bodies we just throw it away we
just
it'll come out of your body you'll just
throw it away but i think a lot of it
will be like
will somebody come to collect it it'll
be it'll be sex robots it'll be stim
it'll be weird stimuli
it'll be they'll still be [ __ ] and
everything but it'll be just a weird
it's going to go into you know the way
that these augmented reality games or
virtual reality feels i think that it's
very possible that like porn gets so
[ __ ] powerful and crazy way powerful
it's destroying people's real sex drives
it's destroying people yeah i'm one of
those people yeah it's wild yeah good
evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one